it's a different kind of strategy than
most it's not the I need to get a
million subscribers on my channel it's
getting the right people on your show so
you can build your business sell it and
then build your other business overseas
for your business referrals are so
critical thinking about who could be
good referral Partners you're taking
Canadians and then taking them to Europe
the lawyers who are experts in moving
businesses over the accountants who are
experts in Italy or Greece or wherever
you're going to go those are great
relationships to start to build now then
that sets you up because they could help
refer clients into you as well I was
like oh okay well we already have
clients who are moving here and we're
helping them with the legal we need
something to help them figure out their
finances talk to Sarah who's the guy
building those relationships is the
fastest way to start getting that
business off the ground now how do you
do that with we're talking YouTube
content or Instagram content I guess I
could call them and say hey uh you want
to do a YouTube together interview them
and say hey what do you see about people
coming over to whatever Italy what are
the things that's the show the show is
not actually for the consumer the show
is having people on who are your
potential referral Partners it's a
business development show
I kind of have I think a unique
situation and I'm looking just for some
feedback from you for your experience so
I am a sir I'm a self-employed certified
financial planner
so I thought hey you know what there's a
lot of need out there for
the misinformation that's out there for
what to do for financial planning like I
hear it all the time so financial
literacy is really bad out there and
there's a lot of bad information out
there so I thought when I start doing
some YouTube videos start a channel
um hopefully grow my business as well
I'm in Ontario so I can only practice in
Ontario but I can get licenses across
Canada so you know I was looking at your
course saying who's your Market well
initially currently my market right now
would be Ontario people and clients that
I'm looking to attract would be more
like on the professional self-employed
basis like me that's who I work with and
higher asset values like half a million
or more however I want to get the
message out to anybody whether they need
to start an resp
or you know save for a house or whatever
they're probably not going to become
clients but you know they need the
information as well that's the one thing
now what I've learned is I just can't do
videos like I did a few videos and my
compliance to take them down they're not
approved so we're heavily regulated the
one benefit is that we have a lot of
pre-approved material that I can just
read word for word or put in my
intonation maybe change a little bit
however I've learned that my process of
approval takes about two weeks every
time I send something in and this is I
didn't know this right yeah I thought
I'd send something in I get something
back in 48 hours no I sent something in
two weeks later I get it back they make
some changes resubmit another two weeks
so I've learned that so now my I've
already figured out I got to send in
something one a day basically and have
something going so my challenge right
now is just finding the time on the
schedule like all of us how to do this
while running a practice meeting clients
all that other stuff yeah so that's
currently
uh in five years time
I probably will be retired from this
and living somewhere in Europe because
we've always looked to be moving there
so okay I've been here for five years
from now is to have a consultancy
financial planning focused for Canadian
expats looking to move to Europe for
example I've already got clients that
have already done that so I'm already in
that we've been Taste of Europe and
that's kind of the long-term Five-Year
Plan so now my challenge is how to merge
these two together having a channel on
basically
my idea is like hey you know maybe do a
video Malaga Spain is a great place to
retire to blah blah blah and here's
someone we talked to that my cousin
lives there and then if you really want
to know how to make a plan to get there
go to my other YouTube channel over
there
which has like Financial Planning and
click there so the one YouTube channel
for today is finding clients with half a
million or more self-employed
professionals get the message out for
other things and then the other one
would be like five years down the road
to build it to have a consultancy and
just to make matters even more
complicated I also became I was promoted
to the vision manager last year so my
other job is recruiting new Financial
professionals something a third YouTube
channel where how to run a successful
financial planning practice
right which would be attracting other
Professionals in the industry
let's go I love it I love it and uh it
happens in in your industry it happens a
lot of medical Industries how much you
can say how much advice you can give uh
you don't want to give medical advice
legal advice same thing franchisees same
thing they can only say some things that
the head office has to improve uh so I
hear you if I'm you I'm first thinking
about
what is the thing that you want to be
building towards like if your business
is is pretty good right now when you
your division head you're managing your
team and you're growing your business a
lot of it's still based off of referrals
anyway right now
uh and you want to be somewhere else in
five years that's the one I would
prioritize the most is let me start
planting the seed to set myself up for
success in five years and maybe that
becomes a three-year plan or two-year
plan because no obviously absolutely
yeah it could be a five year three year
or ten year who knows right but yeah
well but if you start getting tons of
clients for that thing it can help bump
up the the timeline and get there faster
because you got so much domain so build
domain for the right thing if you're
building a YouTube channel for you know
clients for your consumer business but
then you know you're going to be out in
a couple years it's almost not worth it
um well so one tidbit because there's a
lot of information I got to present like
for example I just have to maintain and
grow my current business because when I
leave I sell my practice to another
advisor so the bigger it is the better
it's going to be and you know it's it's
not just I can't keep it stagnant I want
to still bring in yeah uh so really if I
could get like 10 clients a year at half
a million that's fine that's all I need
who are the best referral partners for
your current business and for the Europe
business it's been starting now a bit
after about five years to get referrals
it wasn't at the beginning but I'd say
it got most of my referrals from the
accountants that I work with okay and
what about for the your business
I guess it would have to be my clients
start talking about it because one has
already moved there
so that would be a referral one is
working to move there in five to ten
years I don't really have anybody else
so that especially for your business
referrals are so critical I mean I don't
have to tell you that but you know for
people watching too thinking about who
could be good referral Partners if
you're if you're taking Canadians and
then taking them to Europe the the
lawyers who are experts in moving
businesses over the accountants who are
experts in Italy or Greece or wherever
you're going to go and send people to uh
those are great relationships to start
to build now
yeah and then that sets you up because
they could help refer clients into you
as well I was like oh okay well we
already have clients who are moving here
and we're helping them with the legal we
need something to help them figure out
their finances talk to Sarah she's the
guy so building those relationships is
the fastest way to start getting that
business off the ground uh now how do
you do that with you're talking YouTube
content or Instagram content so you I
guess I could call them and say hey uh
you want to do a YouTube together with
and interview them and say hey what do
you see about people coming over to
whatever Italy and what are the things
that's that's the show so the show
because of all the compliance and
because of the kind of timeline that
you're working on the show is not
actually for uh the consumer the show is
having people on who are your potential
referral Partners it's a business
development show yeah so lawyers never
get asked to do interviews on anything
yeah so if you go in and say hey do you
want to be a potential partner for me
and maybe refer business to each other
they're getting hit up all the times
with business opportunities and like
you're just another financial advisor
that they're that they have to kind of
SWAT away and decide if they actually
want to do something with you but if you
say hey I'd love to interview you for my
YouTube channel that's going to talk
about how Canadians can either you know
invest if it's a community market or how
Canadians can move overseas that's what
my channel is all dedicated towards like
really you got a channel for that sure
I'd happy I'd be happy to come on and
then you spend an hour with them
interviewing them now you built a
relationship
and now they're asking hey Serge what do
you do like you're the financial guy huh
we might have some clients for you yeah
so it almost doesn't matter how well
that video does it's the point is to not
reach consumers but to connect with
potential referral Partners so it's
business development for you
yeah yeah
that's right
is it anywhere in Europe or specific
countries you're trying to move into
uh well uh most are going to be in the
the Latin speaking languages so or the
the southern coast of Spain Italy
um Portugal you know things like that
Portugal yeah yeah and the laws are
similar but different so you need a
referral Network yeah so one client
right now so I'm Eastern European by
background so the niche that I've kind
of fell into is that uh most of my
clients that I work with that are also
Eastern European Romania for example
that's where I'm from they've come here
they've worked here for 10 20 30 years
and some of them have decided they want
to move back into Europe for whatever
the reason so they sell everything here
they go back there and because Romanian
is a Latin based language they're
picking Spain or Italy instead of going
back to Romania or it could even be back
to Romania but that's kind of the niche
and uh so far with that one client that
did it we talked with an international
accountant we did all the paperwork we
helped them set up figured out what have
to do with the rrsps all that stuff so
my idea was if you're Canadian and it
could be might not just be an expat
retiring it could be like right now
people are traveling and working around
the world so even if you're like in your
30s or whatever and you're deciding you
want to go and spend some time in Europe
and learn the language you still need
tax information and what to do with your
rsps back home now I wouldn't be able to
be paid like I am paid now where I
manage assets it'd be more like a
consultancy fee almost like this is what
happens is we can set you up with a
number here whatever bank account
whatever it will be more like helping
people get there but I've got the
knowledge of if you're coming from
Canada
I know it's I know exactly what's going
to happen what you have to worry about
that's kind of what I'm selling here
I love it so it's then connecting with
all of the international lawyers who are
dealing with this who are the experts
and then you have them on your show
doing interviews to build relationships
and then my lead magnet could be the the
checklist this will be the top 10 things
you got to do if you want to move to
Italy or Spain or whatever right yeah
100 yeah and and the the goal that
you'll drive a lot more business from
the people you have on the show than the
people who watch the show yeah so the
goal is to have like if you do a show a
week over the next year then you have 50
connections to International lawyers
that maybe not all of them pass your
business but if 10 of them do and it's
an ongoing source of business for you
that it's not just this one-off deal
right that's the strength of having it
they have people all the time coming in
that that builds your entire business
yeah
yeah
okay
I mean International for me like I just
finished going through the Visa process
to get to the US and I had to work
through across the border lawyer to help
and set up cross-border Banking and like
it's a giant pain and it I I solved it
through connections you know through
people who were referrals like I didn't
know who the right person actually the
first person I hired was the wrong
person we had the fire to get somebody
to help us who had the right answer so
one of the biggest mistakes that people
make is they don't think about business
development in the content
so especially for you if it's heavily
regulated you can only say so many
things you interviewing a lawyer about
people moving over is a lot easier to
get through than you giving RSP advice
to people that has to be screened by
your organization yeah it's got to be a
totally different channel of different
mindset yet it is it is
consultancy but not financial planning
let's say it's like what are the rules
that you might encounter like if you
leave or do stuff if I talk anything at
all about financial planning
then I run the risk of my combining that
should be on this other channel yep and
that's going to be reviewed and embedded
basically so
yeah so the show's just about hey I'm
Serge and I I love helping Canadians set
up in another country whether it's uh as
a second residence or now it's a
retirement residence and figuring out
all the financial elements to be able to
move over there and still manage uh
manage their their life and their
business and today I got a special guest
who is a international lawyer who
specializes in other legal aspects and
so we're going to talk about some of the
things you have to think about when you
move to Greece
yeah right and then so and that's the
show and then you just ask questions and
it's the same questions what do
Canadians have to keep in mind when
they're moving over there you know one
of the biggest mistakes that you think
that these people make before they they
come over there right like you keep
telling you the show though so is it a
YouTube like still videos you put on
YouTube or is it like a live show I
don't what is what is it yeah yeah well
so it's so that you can call it a show
okay so that you're not just making
YouTube videos it's like I've got a show
on YouTube and and I interview experts
to have them to help Canadians move
abroad and you're an act expert in the
legal side of things in Portugal and I
love the interview I mean as long as
your English is halfway decent but most
people at that point will have like if
you're a professional International
lawyer in one of these countries you
speak English it may not be your first
language but you can get by in English
um so you call it a show just to make it
more as opposed to like oh you know I
want to do a YouTube video yeah yeah
yeah it's like you have a show and this
is an ongoing thing that you're doing
ideally every week where you have
different experts on sharing their
advice and their story it's a it's a
really easy show to host it's the same
questions that you just keep asking
whatever you're curious about
um you don't run into any of the
compliance issues because you're talking
about the legal aspects not the
financial side of things uh
and then you get business from them
because they need they know all the
legal stuff but they need the financial
guys and that's where you come in yeah
and I was thinking like because I love
to travel and I love food it could also
almost be like uh it can almost be like
a travel food relocation show like you
know start off with because we do travel
a lot so I have a huge opportunity to
make my own videos while I'm there
um we go a couple times a year uh build
a database of it and say you know when
when you're here you should try this
stuff at this place or what I get this
is the street that everybody goes to
kind of thing and then kind of get into
that and then from there go into the
interview aspect of it like I really I
love to travel in the food I'm sorry the
travel's great the food I don't know how
much you want to get in you know this
limits on the food I'm half Italian so I
it's easy to overeat when I go home but
um
and it might even be worth like if you
can get I don't know who the top lawyers
are the top potential referral partners
for you are in in those countries but if
you can line up an interview with one of
the senior Partners there maybe that's
worth a trip on its own yeah that wasn't
scheduled and now I'm surprised we went
to Portugal next weekend to this
interview
yeah yeah I know that's great yeah okay
it builds the connection in a
relationship and especially if they meet
you and they see you uh they're way more
likely to want to do business with you
okay
yeah so now we don't need to have
a hundred thousand followers on your
channel no you're you're making a
Content yes still to help and it's still
gonna be valuable content but you're
making the content to help you grow your
business through referral Partnerships
yeah
it's uh it's definitely needs
Focus time on the calendar and that's
the biggest challenge
um just even I haven't been able to
attend all the movement makers maybe two
two of them I'm always thinking I'm
going to watch them afterwards because
for whatever reason a management meeting
comes up or whatever and if I don't plan
it ahead I just can't get it done so I
think that's going to be my next biggest
challenge to
everything you say is great now how do I
do that basically pick up the phone and
start calling and booking yeah you or I
don't I don't know if you have somebody
on your team or you have an assistant or
um or you can hire somebody to to help
you do it
um I use a guy named Beau and that's
like he books all the people from my
shows and I'm happy to introduce you to
Beau if you want or just you find
somebody to help you do the bookings
because then you you like even this I
didn't book this my assistant booked
this and now we're here doing this okay
okay I'm showing up it's it's four
o'clock surgery now we're gonna do this
let's go uh so to have somebody do the
Outreach and then put it in the calendar
then all you have to do is show up it's
a lot easier to do a half hour hour show
where you're just asking questions then
all of the back and forth and research
and calling and emails and follow-ups
and confirmations and making sure they
got the link and all that stuff
and you do the interviews through
Instagram or some other way that doesn't
matter Zoom or whatever it's a mix like
this is an Instagram live so this is on
Instagram uh my other interviews you
know like Tony Robbins and Matthew
McConaughey you know we did on Zoom so
we just set up a zoom link but now
everybody has Zoom right like you have a
zoom link so everybody knows how to use
zoom now like that's one of the big
blessings of kova is we all figured out
how to use zoom
um so but that's pretty like that's
that's low wage work like that's not
that doesn't require you and your
sophisticated expertise usually someone
who's friendly and who knows how to do
some research
to go off and find these people and
introduce the show and then figure out
the time I mean it's Europe so it's
depending on the country you're looking
at you know six seven eight hours ahead
so it would be a morning show for you
afternoon evening for them
but that's that's an easy like if you
just have to show up for an hour and
it's all been taken care of that's a lot
easier than if you have to do all the
bookings
okay build the connections due to some
shows I won't be able to monetize that
at all until well if I do that uh I
gotta figure out because any outside
activity I also have to advise right so
if any other income that's not part of
this so it's more like building a
foundation and you know ready to go
because when I do uh sell the practice
there'll be some money to keep us going
for a couple of years for sure while I
build that other practice but I guess
having the connections in advance will
definitely help I mean you could you can
apply the same model to your current
practice right now yeah it's just you're
not targeting lawyers and accountants in
Portugal you're targeting Ontario or
Canada
yeah I mean even just Ontario if you
there's enough here
yep like how many accountants and
lawyers have been asked to come on shows
and talk about what like nobody
yeah well that's true it's true
a lot of mispers Mis information
misperceptions even within the
professional industry like accountants
assume what what I'm what I know what
I'm I'm gonna say I assume what
accountants are considered lawyers are
going to say right so that's part of the
whole financial literacy thing like
let's get all talking and make sure that
the right information is out there
because now with you know you can type
anything in
people don't understand why I can't give
them an insurance quote if I don't know
anything about them it's like well go to
the dentist and tell them that you want
your tooth extracted without asking them
to do x-rays like it's so it's it's so
hard to in this transactional business
to get people to understand and that's
part of the reason I want to do these
videos as well right why it's important
so so I mean it's it's Ontario
accountants are the number one driver
for business right now then go make a
show interviewing Ontario accountants
and you can go drive to them you know
zones are not in like I don't know where
you live but you know if they're in
Sudbury or something maybe you don't
want to take the drive out there
but they're easy to get on their show
this is the thing like you're not trying
to get Elon Musk on your show or the
rock or somebody it's it's an accountant
in Richmond Hill yeah nobody's ever
asked their opinion on anything for a
video and now you're the only guy who's
ever paid any attention to them and and
they're going to come on and now you
build a relationship together right like
it's a it's super easy to get a yes
in this kind of model and then hopefully
pass on business to you and again not
everybody will but if you did 50 shows
in 50 weeks you'll get you'll get
clients and the Beautiful Thing is once
you get it like once you have the
relationship they keep giving you
clients it's not just a one-off thing
they're they're always having new people
come in and they can always pass it on
the surge
um and you build an asset in the show
that then when you sell your book you
could sell the show alongside the book
yeah yeah right and you can just
transition to host
so maybe for six months you you co-host
with the person bringing someone else
before I I teach them teach him or her
uh the whole thing and uh moving on from
there yeah yeah for three to six months
you're you're co-hosting with them and
then they take over the channel so don't
put the channel off your name that
channel
that's a channel off of
whatever Financial yeah you know the
company name and then it could be
anybody you're just a face fork for now
you start interviewing accountants build
the book I mean if the goal is 10 to 10
clients a month that's that's a year
10 clients a year yeah well I mean
because no because so basically because
I've got multiple things recruiting and
the clients and I've got my own client
base don't need to get 100 clients here
right but it got to be a certain asset
level like half a million or one million
plus yeah then that'd be okay right so
it's not that stringent or hard to do
that but it's just
there's multiple balls in here juggling
basically right yeah so it'll be it will
be a struggle yeah if I do then it's
good
right well you just need one good
accountant relationship to get 10
clients that's not you're not coming in
asking for the Moon
my part of the pie and that's about it
right so it's completely achievable if
you even the I mean one show a week is
aggressive but even if you did one a
month where you went in and talked to
accountants and you interviewed them
to find out accountants in Toronto area
is not that difficult no no to contact
them like it's not International
Warriors that's so much easier
yeah email them as easy set up a time is
not that difficult and now they're on
your show and to get one person yes then
giving you 10 10 clients for the year is
easy and you're building up an asset
that then you can sell to the next
person it's actually it might be a good
time now to do it before uh the tax
season here in uh Canada as they could
say you know what do you want to tell
your clients that they want to make sure
they do before they come and see you and
then afterwards because you can't talk
with them from February February March
right yeah but that's when you moved you
moved to the lawyers yeah you know when
the accountants are too busy you move
the Liars because the lawyers can pass
your business too yeah
yeah
cool that's that's the stress so it's a
different kind of strategy than most
it's not the I need to get a million
subscribers on my channel it's getting
the right people uh on your show so you
can build your business sell it and then
build your other business overseas
that's right
that's right you got it I love it man
well there's your strategy thank you I
think it's the work yeah it's great I
mean it's it's actually a pretty easy
business to build
like you could start you could start
this afternoon
just fill up a list of all the
accountants in your area and just again
because me going to call them and say
hey I'm a financial planner do you want
to meet it's yeah I think
they get hit up all the time the
roadblock that hit me and you know it
hits in your brain is like oh man I got
to go through compliance oh it's going
to take forever so it's kind of it
slowed me down significantly at the
beginning like I was all gung-ho at the
beginning I was making videos and all
that stuff and I was like and then I
send in something and they go and this
is where it's gonna go and they said oh
we looked at your YouTube channel
you should take all those ones down
because it didn't go through completely
and I was like ah
so
yeah because you got to be careful that
we're we're actually we're representing
that company even though I'm
self-employed independent it's under a
big umbrella right it doesn't matter you
know someone's still sponsoring you
behind the background there right so
yeah no I get it in any regulated
industry and or like franchises it's
it's very similar so this this is a good
little work around hack and actually
would perform even better especially
given your timeline of how quickly you
want to make it happen to do the
Partnerships and just get to refill
business in to blow up the company okay
cool man thank you all right well good
luck keep us posted and can't wait to
see the show Absolutely take care Serge
so I have the
experience and I have the product but I
am completely lost in how to Market what
is the thing that you're selling
I am the reset codes getting people to
reinvent their lives using a five-step
process okay so what's the content that
you're making right now are you making
coaching content yes I'm making coaching
content this is the Instagram yes that's
mine there she is all right coach my mom
I'm following perfect okay so where are
so you're doing IG lives here and then
are you bringing people up or this is
what are you doing here no I just post
the reels and posts I do a stream yard
lives okay YouTube videos
oh okay so you're doing it so you have
people join you on stream yard and then
you post that to YouTube after yes got
it okay and then the link here is to
your YouTube channel so let's go check
that out to get some here we go
why are you laughing
when you have the the YouTube
Channel you are in big trouble no this
is good it's all love it's all love
Barry come on it's all love okay so this
is this is this is it right then looking
at the right one yes that's it okay and
then these are
these are the coaching sessions you're
doing
no I I have done private coaching
sessions but they are not on YouTube
yeah with my friends and family
and then I I have been able to to help
them with my
strategy of SWOT analysis to find their
strengths their weaknesses their their
opportunities and then the threats
but I can't take them further on how to
monetize the talents that they have
rediscovered
okay so so marketing now we need to see
you coaching
okay
we need content of you coaching so first
off I wouldn't stream anything to
YouTube so and on your channel here
you've got some videos it's great I
wouldn't do it as streamed I would just
upload it as a regular video because
streamed videos get a lot less long-term
views on content but
you speaking to the camera is is great
but it's not as good as you coaching if
you're a coach
okay like the fact that you can make a
post what was your Instagram
uh talking about like what's stopping
you from growth by the way I love look
at the where are you this is crazy where
are you standing right here
in in Calgary that's beautiful wow thank
you I love it so but like that's a great
it's a great looking video and you're
talking about what's stopping you from
growth awesome but that doesn't mean
that you're a great coach
the fact that you can just speak the
camera doesn't mean that you're a great
coach
okay so if you want to sell coaching I
need to see you coaching okay that comes
now to the Second Challenge I have I set
out to like I thought I thought that my
Niche was people who have burned out
like people above 50 my age great
who have been out and who think they are
a failure who are failed and they are
struggling not knowing where to have to
continue and I thought I set out to help
them reinvent themselves but now I got a
few weeks ago when I got more than 200
subscribers on YouTube
to take the the analytics very seriously
so I went to the audience analysis
analysis and I realized in the
audience disagree disaggregated data on
gender and age that most of the people
who are watching my videos 64 percent of
them are men
and
not 67 percent of them are men and 64
percent are between 18 and 24.
and another the other 30 30 how many
percent are between 25 and 34 and 34. so
there's nobody above 50 or where maybe
they don't have enough data to to give
me and so I became completely lost
I don't know now should I continue doing
the videos the way I'm doing them or
should I change to some Snappy way of
doing things the consumers are more
younger people so I got lost and that's
why I started doing live streaming
because I didn't know how to do videos
that would suit that age group should I
continue the way I'm doing the videos or
I should focus on those age groups well
you're saying you don't know how to make
videos to hit the age group but you're
already hitting the age group in your
analytics that the the bigger question
about that is who do you watch you want
to serve so
does I mean you started the business and
you thought you'd be helping people who
are 50 plus who are struggling with kind
of the next step in their life uh
now you're helping you're actually
helping people on your content who are
much younger
does it matter to you if you if you're
doing resetting for people does it
matter to you
their age
it does not I mean I was just mind blown
by because I focused on something else
and then I got a different result but
you know as a communicator I'm a I'm a
journalist so as a communicator you know
the generations the way you communicate
to them is different
so I don't know now maybe I have to do
some Snappy videos to to come down to
the generation or I keep the way I'm
doing I don't
um that's where I got challenged
so you're a reset coach and and like
your IG bio says you help reinvent
yourself or you help people reinvent
themselves with the five-step process to
rebuild self-confidence improve your
network so you help people reinvent
themselves
yeah this is what this is that's who you
love helping the most yep cool so where
you come in and help us anytime somebody
needs a reinvention which might be when
they're 50 and they're hitting their job
and trying to move the next step it
could also be
as they're trying to figure out what
their first job should be or their
second job or their first marriage or
their second marriage or whatever right
I mean you take athletes who are done at
35 and they can't compete anymore what
do they go off and do next they have to
reinvent themselves right so
it's less about an age demo and more
about the life stage that somebody's at
when they need a reinvention okay
so uh I don't even worry necessarily
about having
um snappier content or finding which age
group to go to I'd focus more on doing
coaching sessions with people who need
to reinvent themselves and let the right
people come find you
so if you're doing your coaching
sessions it's with people who are like
you've got 233 followers right now on
Instagram let's go you know first the
first 233 is the hardest 233. so in
there who is looking to reinvent
themselves right now and then that
becomes the coaching content that you do
okay
so it's regular whether you if you want
to use stream yard cool you can
Instagram allows you to hack other
people's audiences as well so if you're
going live with somebody on Instagram
Their audience gets to see that you're
live with them too uh they might
um promote it as a collaborator as well
but it's seeing you coaching so that's
the best kind of content you can make it
doesn't mean that you stop doing like I
love it you're outside in Calgary
beautiful mountains you got a great
message for growth it's awesome uh cool
thank you that doesn't mean you have to
stop those but that content won't lead
you to generate as as many clients
if you're selling coaching if you wanted
to be a speaker
then maybe
but if you want to be a coach and you
want to sell coaching because you
already are a coach and if you want to
be a coach but like what are you selling
if you want to sell coaching I need to
see you coaching
okay so if I was doing Instagram
breakdowns if that was my business right
cool I we just did a quick little
example okay okay Mary like look here's
your Instagram and here's we gotta
here's what we have to switch up then
somebody else would come in and I could
help coach them on Instagram and then I
could sell my Instagram coaching
Services right uh it's not what I want
to do but that would be the model so
same thing for you you're getting people
who need a reset in their life
and creating content with them
and coaching them through the process
coaching through the five uh not the
five hours the five what's this
five-step reset process reset that's
what it was not five hours you put them
through your five-step process
and then I get to see oh Mary's awesome
maybe she can help me too
and for anybody who's looking for a
reset in their life
maybe they call you now but it's not
depending on age or gender or country or
whatever else
if that's not actually important to you
like if you don't care if they're men or
women or from Canada or United States or
Italy or you know wherever no I don't
care I just want to serve right but who
but serving people who need a reset yep
so that's what you're all about so it's
not about the demo like how you Niche
down is not based off of the demo or
like age group it's based off of or
gender it's based off of do they need a
reset right now in their life
okay because when I saw that I thought
maybe I I missed my like my calling was
to use my experience to help people who
have gone through divorce and I so I
didn't want to say divorced women
because that will continue the stigma
the word divorce so I I so now I don't
know if I've missed my mission
oh
I just continue with
resetting their lives their finances
they are I don't know
well you you have it you haven't missed
anything you just continue to reset
right so you know in your own language
like here's the thing like do you want
to help
yes women who are divorced and that's
where you want to be the expert at or do
you want to help anybody who needs to
have a reset in their life
I think everybody I wanted to help women
in particular because I thought that
those are the people who have a big
issue on trying to find themselves when
they when they fail at something
but well maybe that was just some
subjective analysis
I don't know
well a lot of guys are lost too
a lot of guys are lost too kind of scary
a lot of guys are lost too but here's
what here's what will happen if you
actually do
if you actually do coaching sessions
like if you if you start messaging your
233 followers and you start dming them
and say hey if you need a reset right
now I'm happy to do a free coaching
session with you
we'll put it live on Instagram
what you'll end up finding is
different people be attracted to you but
they still have their own version of
what they need a reset of and you may
end up niching down
it's based off of still like matching
what your heart wants to do with what
had kind of practically makes sense but
the niche may be completely different
like maybe why are all these 24 year
olds uh needing resets or it's like 18
to 24. well they're trying to figure out
going to college or not do I go to
college is it still a good thing to do
they're in their first job do I do I
stay in this job or not I thought I
wanted to be an engineer but now I
realize that I hate it and I want to be
something else right they're trying to
figure out do I stay in this
relationship you know do I marry my high
school sweetheart or do I go and you do
something completely different so but
people are having resets all over the
place throughout their lives
as you start actually doing the coaching
you'll find the best people that you
love working with the most
okay so it's in the doing like if you
did a hundred coaching sessions with
people
all around and not not being judged not
not that you are judgmental but not
saying it has to be women 50 plus
divorced
and you just said you need a reset I'm
going to help you navigate that
okay you you have it open to more people
and you'll you'll end up gravitating to
and pulling in the better clients to
then actually go hire you for coaching
as long as it's still within like what
you want to do like if you say yeah I
can help somebody navigate
being fired from their first job and now
moving on to figure out their second job
or having a midlife crisis instead of
buying the Ferrari hire coach Mary
should help you out instead right is it
better return on investment there here
if I pull up my most recent book right
momentum
on the back
I I said what you can use she's got
there you go you got your coffee too
like on the back like use this book to
launch your business write your book
begin a healthy habit create your
Masterpiece kick off your podcast start
your YouTube channel game momentum and
the goals that matter to you the most
because these are the most common things
that I get asked to help people with
so it'll be similar with you like hey
work with Coach Mary to to help you
reset your life to like what if you've
gone through divorce figuring out your
first career you know swapping to your
next job trying to get into college or
not like whatever the main things are
because ultimately I don't care if I'm
helping somebody launch their first book
or start a YouTube channel I just care
about people getting their message out
to the world
absolutely it makes a lot of sense that
becomes like how do I create how do you
create a Regular Show at least once a
week like the the the starting point is
once a week the ambition point is daily
so somewhere in there like where do we
want to play but at least once a week of
about you coaching people and anybody
who needs a reset and that's who you
then bring on look at movement makers I
don't care what country you're from what
what what uh your background is Men
Women age like we've got somebody asking
yesterday how what's the diversity like
in movement makers it's like it's all
over the place like
lots of men lots of women absolutely all
sorts of age groups like so but what's
what's common is everybody wants
everybody's got a message and they want
to get out to the world
and so that's the thing that binds
everybody together so for you like it
doesn't matter where they come from but
everybody needs everybody comes to you
is looking for a reset to make that next
shift in their life
okay that makes a lot of sense thank you
so now talking about publishing a book I
have a two complete manuscripts of my in
my computer I don't know how to go about
them publishing them so I am challenged
by the copyright issues or how to get
the books out to the public so what's
the copyright issue
I had a a Blog that somebody downloaded
and published a book and published it in
a book and had the audacity to send it
to me to edit it for the person
and so I really got blocked and I I
really don't don't know so now I have I
have as a as a communicator I have I
write and write and write I do Knowledge
Management and stuff
but I write the things and they stay
there I don't know now how to I really
don't have that
push
to bring them out
well you have to decide if you're going
to go self-publish or try to work with a
publisher
if it's self-published you can get them
up on Amazon today you you could I mean
you gotta you gotta get a design for the
cover but it could be basic like you
don't need the beautiful thing about
Amazon is you can keep updating it so
you can launch it and you can change the
cover if you don't like it you can you
can change the manuscript like you can
keep updating it if you want but if it's
just to get a book you could
self-publish it and you can have it
ready to go you have an e-book that you
sell from your own website like you can
you can have it up if you want if you if
you want to get it published and you you
go with the publisher you start
submitting it you could talk to Kira
who's my business partner in in Freedom
House about getting the book out to the
world
um
so those are your two options right
there's pros and cons to both
but you could like if you just wanted to
get it up you could the the challenge
with the book is you still need to
Market it
okay because having a book on Amazon
doesn't mean that it's anybody's gonna
buy it
so I because now I I have a very tiny
budget for that so I would go tilt more
towards self-publishing and
so you're saying if I'm going to do
self-publishing it's easier but I have
more work to do
yeah exactly it's it's it's
maybe not easier it's like it's easier
to get up I guess
you know but it's it's harder for you in
terms of it's going to take more time to
to create and post and figure out how to
do it yourself or or work with someone
even a movie makers like Terry Wade
Thompson could probably be a resource to
help you he's done a whole bunch of
different books other people have
self-published their books too but
Terry's gone through the process a lot
so you might have some tips to get you
there faster the the challenge with it
though becomes
the book without marketing is not going
to generate more business for you
okay
so I would love to see you start making
more money
and then you can afford to hire whoever
you need to to do whatever else you need
to
right so people tend to default to more
like okay oh I need to write a blog or I
need to write a book or I need to like
just create more but
creating more doesn't mean that you're
going to get more clients and get paid
more so
if you're a coach having a book does it
add some credibility uh maybe you know
like these days it doesn't really matter
that much if you have a book or not if
it's with the publisher maybe it's in a
bookstore maybe but are you still buying
books and bookstores you know I don't
know it's like it's not what it used to
be the reason I write a book is because
you want to birth it into the world you
get a big message and for my books like
this just this is better in a book than
it is in a series of videos
but
I didn't need this book to like
immediately generate business for me
if I was you I would focus on how do I
grow my coaching business you might have
big Ambitions and huge things you want
to do and maybe you start your own
publishing company I don't know you got
lots of things that you want to work on
uh but what's the fastest path to start
making some money inside of your big
mission
and if you're self-coaching the fastest
path is coaching so what's going to help
you generate coaching clients
your two Best Bets are coaching content
so like a book isn't coaching content a
book is you being a thought leader again
right so coaching content ideally videos
where you're showing right
um and any potential Partnerships like
who are they
uh who are people going to when they
need a reset so for example you
mentioned divorce cool go talk to the
top 50 divorce attorneys in Calgary
and say here's what I do
right so that somebody's going through
the divorce maybe they recommend coach
Mary
like hey if you're struggling with this
you should talk to coach Mary
that makes sense no I was talking about
the books because I already have the
manuscripts completed so it's as well as
finding a way to get it out and instead
of keeping it in my computer
it doesn't save anybody there
sure yeah a hundred percent but and like
you're not serving anybody if if we're
not generating Revenue too absolutely
right so like if you build the coaching
business up and then you have 10 coaches
underneath you and now you've got a team
you can serve a whole lot more people
whether it's through short Snappy
content or books or speaking tours or
whatever else that you want to do right
so usually you know the immediate
priority you can tell me you can tell me
no it's like hey you know what I don't
need to make money for the next three
years I'm good so tell me what to do
next okay but usually like monetize
becomes important and what's the fastest
way is through coaching content and
through referral Partnerships so like
divorce attorneys is a good one
um thinking about other people whether
it could be accountants it could be
lawyers like other lawyers other
accountants like someone who's just sold
their like when I sold my business I
could have used you when I was 22. I
sold my business
I made money great but I didn't know
what to do next in my life
like the thing that I just dedicated
myself to was God
it's a good problem to have but it's
still a problem like okay what do I do
next and I just explored a bunch of
different things but
um maybe talking to you could have
helped right if my lawyer said hey talk
to coach Mary she might be able to help
you
so who are the people who can give you
referrals
because they're dealing with these
people all day long and a divorce
attorney
is not guiding people through how to
reset their life they're just they're
just guiding people through how to not
get screwed in the divorce right like
it's not their expertise yeah so
uh and it doesn't just have to be
Calgary I say Calgary because that's
where you are and it's it's it's close
but you could make Partnerships with
divorce attorneys across North America
like get so much business from
from your marketing strategy that then
you can do whatever you want with books
and speaking and employees and whatever
else you want to go off and create
so like the book exists on your lot on
your computer awesome but there's still
a there's still a Time cost to get it
like if you're gonna figure out the
sub-publishing route there's still a
Time cost to figure all that out and get
it up
okay thank you so much and before you go
do I need a business license to do to go
into entrepreneurship in Canada so
there's a couple types of businesses in
Canada you've got your you know sole
proprietorship
uh which just means that you're running
it off your name or you can set up a
corporation
the the pros and cons
um the main issue is around liability
How likely you to be sued so if you go
Corporation you accept your own
Corporation the easy you know you need
to get a lawyer to help you it's not
expensive but there's annual filing fees
so you're probably spending at least two
thousand dollars a year just to maintain
your corporation
so not the end of the world but if
you're not making money two thousand
dollars a year is still two thousand
dollars a year so the starting point is
you just do sole proprietorship and it's
based off of your name
the only
um downside is if you get sued
then they come after you personally
okay so now you gotta ask and you know
I'm not giving legal advice here over
Instagram but to find out if I need it
then I'll go get a lawyer yeah well so
it's like if you think you're going to
be sued you think about the types of
advice you're giving you know coaching
is a it's a low likelihood scenario
right like I leave I I run a dance
studio here right like the largest dance
school in Canada for salsa dancing
um we have I don't know a million
dollars liability insurance like if
somebody comes in we've we've never had
anybody sue us
um but if somebody slips on the floor
and breaks their leg or something like
we've never had that but if that
happened right that's why we have
insurance but that if I didn't have a
corporation
if Trinidad salsa was not a corporation
then they could come after and Sue Evan
Carmichael okay right so uh if I'm just
giving YouTube strategies or something
they're probably not gonna like the
likelihood of somebody suing me is a lot
lower
so for some Industries it's very high
you know for salsa dancing or anything
physical anything anything health
related if you wanna people Sue like
crazy there so you want to make sure
your your uh it's a corporation for sure
and you have insurance but uh at the
beginning in a coaching business
uh the likelihood's pretty low but it's
one of those things like as soon as you
start making money from it it's good to
turn it into a corporation
um if you ever want to have business
partners too you need to have a
corporation I don't know if you ever
plan on giving up Equity or shares in
your company but uh then you need to
have a corporation to make that happen
okay thank you so much yeah
all right Mary well grateful thank you
so much so next step is we got to start
booking like action items to Do's book
the show book guests that you for you to
coach and make a list of 50 divorce
attorneys in Calgary to go start
connecting with and see if you can build
a relationship
that's how we started to build this
business
thank you very much
very much amazing Mary we love you have
a great week and uh we'll see you in
mover makers next week thank you very
much to see me coach another
entrepreneur one on one check the video
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see
you there it feels weird to say but it's
having you lower expectations here's
what happens when you have really high
expectations then when you don't do it
you lose a little more self-confidence